Hey friend, here I am. Not me, it's AWS
I am identity and access management.
Very very important concept in AWS. In
this video, I will show you how AWS IM
helps you in securing your applications
from hackers and scammers. Again I will
use clear and simple diagrams with a
stepbystep approach so that later you
can confidently explain this concept to
anyone because AWS IM is a very commonly
asked topics. So what are we waiting
for? Let's start.
What is AWS IM? Identity and access
management.
Be ready after listening to this answer.
you will be 100% confident on this
concept. Let's understand with the help
of an example. Suppose your company is
using AWS cloud and there are two
applications hosted inside it. One is a
email application and another one is the
payroll application. You are the
developer or architect managing this AWS
setup for your company. Okay. Now there
are three users trying to access these
apps. So the first is a regular
employee. User A regular employee of
your company. Second user B is someone
who is the HR of your company. Okay? He
is also an employee. And third is the
user C which is outside from your
company not the employee of your
company. Okay? Now listen carefully. As
a AWS developer, you you will take the
help of AWS AM okay identity and access
management. You will set up this service
in your AWS account to decide who can
access which application. For example,
the email application here. Okay. Both
the user A and user B, company employee
and company HR will be able to access
but the user C is unauthorized. He will
will not be able to access this email
application. Okay. Similarly for the
payroll application only and only the
user B only the HR will be able to
access not even user A because payroll
will be accessed by or you know
distributor pay will pay will be
distributed by HR only. Right? So that
is how IM works. It authenticates user
to check who they are and authorize them
to give permission what they can access.
Okay. So basically IM implement
authentication and authorization
concepts. Remember this. And yes, if you
are confused between authentication and
authorization, don't worry. I will
explain this in upcoming question. But
before that, here is the simple
definition.
AWS IM is a secure cloud-based service
in AWS that helps organizations verify
users and control access to AWS services
and resources. So whatever services are
present in your AWS,
IM will control the access for them.
Okay. So in short, IM will not allow
unauthorized users to access your AWS
applications. That's it. And this
diagram and this definition in this book
will help you in doing the quick
revision before your interviews. Before
moving forward, a quick note here. I
created a complete AWS interview
preparation boot camp for you with three
powerful tools. Number three, 200 plus
AWS interview questions from all the
topics step by step even for AWS
beginners like this. Second, a PDF book
for quick lastminut revision. And first
10 AWS mock interviews to practice like
real interviews. Many student have
already cracked interviews with my
courses. All links are in the
description. If interested, great. If
not, no worries. Let's move to the next
question. What are authentication and
authorization? Let's clear these
concepts in just 2 minutes. Suppose you
are a student in a school. Now you open
the website of your school and their
website is asking you to login like
this. If you are a student then a school
must have provided with you some
username and password to login. Right
now by entering these credential here
you are basically verifying your
identity with the school that yes you
are a student or member of this school.
then only this website will allow you to
enter in this websitechool.com
right this concept of identity
verification is called authentication
which basically ask you basically who
are you and you are saying that I am
happy and this is my password once you
enter this the school will check in
their database and find that you are the
student of the school Okay.
Now, authentication means the answer is
only yes or no to give you access or not
to give you access. So when uh when once
you are allowed to login and or you are
not allowed so that's so next part is
authorization. Okay. So after you are
allowed to access then only
authorization will happen. Okay. If you
are not allowed to access, if
authentication fails, then authorization
will not happen. So once you are logged
in inside the website, so then you as a
student you can see these men menus in
your website. All right. But these menu
are just not for you. These are for
other departments also like there in the
school there will be teachers,
administrators, clerical department etc.
Now if your school has these menu okay
so as a student you are authorized to
view only some not all of these menus.
For example as a student you are able to
see this result view result because yes
a student will see result right but but
but as a student you cannot edit the
result. So when a teacher will log in
they can get the access and they can
edit the result that is authorization.
Okay. So similarly you can uh pay the
fees as a student but you do not will be
have the access for the salary that will
be for the teachers for the clerical
administrator other departments right.
So this is authorization.
So it basically based on your user like
you have the student account. So what
rights and access will be provided to
you is the concept of authorization.
Okay. So that is the whole idea and I
hope you got it now and remember
authentication will happen first and
then only authorization.
All right the concept is clear to you.
Here I have written the same definition.
Auong authentication is the process of
verifying the identity of a user by
validating their credentials.
Credentials means username and password.
And authorization is the process of
allowing the authenticated user only to
access to resources. Okay.
Authentication always precedes
authorizations which I already explained
and that is the answer to this question.
What is the key difference between AWS
IM and onprim active directory?
Pause the video think about a second.
Done. Here it is. IM is cloud native
meaning it's for cloud. AD is on on
premises. Okay. It's not and domain
based. It's not on cloud. And here is
the explanation. IM manages permission
for AWS resources not machines. Active
directory manage users devices policies
in Windows networks. Okay. AD is more
related to your Windows. IM is resource
access focused while AD is network
access folder. So basically active
directory is like where all the
employees information is stored on the
windows and IM is the same thing but it
is on the cloud like very much same
thing 90% but it is on the cloud. Okay.
All right. Now if you understand this
then there is one more very important
related concept AWS secrets managers
like this that I have explained in my
complete AWS interview boot camp
many of my students have already used my
courses to crack their interviews now if
you don't want to miss a single question
for your next interview then check out
the boot camp and book link in the
description below.